my beef with the black left is that they
want to keep the focus on what
government or Washington or politicians
or whites in general can do for blacks
or should be doing for blacks instead of
what blacks can do for themselves hi I'm
Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and today
we're talking with Jason Riley he works
at The Wall Street Journal editorial
page and he's the author most recently
of the excellent new book please stop
helping us how liberals make it harder
for blacks to succeed at the start of
the book you write the sober truth is
that the most important civil rights
battles were fought in one for decades
before the Obama presidency the black
underclass continues to face many
challenges but they have to do with
values and habits not oppression from a
manifestly unjust society blacks have
become their own worst enemy and liberal
leaders you don't say are essentially
abetting that what is the typical black
experience and is there this fixation on
a kind of black underclass that no
longer actually exists or is
representative or what what what does it
mean well I don't know that there's a
typical black experience which is
progress in and of itself you have a big
black middle class now most blacks are
not poor in this country but the
problems of the black underclass
continue to dominate the discussion and
rightly so
and they do continue to be
representative of blackness writ large
so to speak we need to talk about these
problems and what I'm talking about is
culture one of the reasons I wrote this
book is I think there's a hesitancy
particularly among those on the left to
discuss black culture and I don't know
how we're going to address those
problems if we're afraid to talk about
them and you target I want to get to
this say much more disturbing is that
half a century after the civil rights
battles were fought and won liberalism
remains much more interested in making
excuses for blacks than in reevaluating
efforts to help them and you talk about
the Civil Rights Acts of 1964 and 65 as
liberalism at its best civil rights
activism you know set the stage for
those victories and what they achieve
well the 1964 act gets at legal
discrimination in the country the 1965
Voting Rights Act makes voter
registration possible an actual voting
possible they made this country a more
just society and I think with Thurgood
Marshall Martin Luther King and Rosa
Parks and the Freedom Riders and those
folks were fighting for was worth
fighting for and I think all narrowly
necessary absolutely necessary and all
Americans can be happy that they made
this country more just then you get
Lyndon Johnson coming in and saying
that's not enough
equal opportunity isn't enough we need
equal results and I question whether
that is a legitimate or even a
reasonable goal since you don't see
equal results among groups historically
in America or anywhere else in the world
maybe the best you can hope for from
government is equal opportunity then
it's up to those groups to take
advantage of those opportunities there's
no question that the black experience
with the possible exception of Native
Americans isn't you know it wasn't
infinitely more punishing an oppressive
experience so it's not completely out of
bounds that you would say you know what
equal opportunity is not enough I mean
it may be wrong but you can you can
understand the impulse what had one of
the results then of Briony go beyond
that that's what I look at overlooked
have these efforts helped or harmed
black Americans as you point out in the
book the black unemployment rate is
essentially double the white or the
national average what are the programs
that were put in place supposedly to
help blacks well these are anti-poverty
these are anti-poverty programs and also
wage floors and I'm talking about
minimum wage laws davis-bacon and so
forth and if you look at black
employment prior to the implementation
of those policies you saw much better
outcomes in the 1940s well into the
1950s you saw black labor participation
rates higher than what we have which and
just to put a button on that it's insane
in an America that was manifestly more
discriminatory that's right is that's
you what you had blacks for all the
legacies of slavery all the legacies of
Jim Crow they couldn't keep throw black
employment from being essentially
parallel with white and
limit in the same environment young
blacks without skills like all you know
young workers who have relatively low
skills are they priced out of the labor
market and then they just can't get work
or are you saying that it's anti-poverty
programs that allow them to get by
without what's the number of factors one
is yes pricing people out of the labor
force when you make it more expensive to
hire people fewer people get hired and
you are particularly hurting less
skilled less experienced workers by by
RIT by raising the cost of hiring them
now the love cells this is an
anti-poverty program but most poor
households are in that category because
they have no workers not because they
have workers who are paid too little
right you can't confuse poor households
with households with minimum-wage
workers right and a lot of that
confusion results in trying to use the
minimum wages intended laughing or the
left or liberals I tend to look at the
person who keeps a job and goes for
making $4 an hour to $6 an hour if they
had success yeah but but they did they
ignore the people who never get on in
everything they know that people never
get hired and they assume that those
people will keep their jobs and and work
at the same number of hours let's look
at poverty between 1940 and 1960 black
poverty in America fell by 40 percentage
points in 20 years that's before civil
rights act before voting rights act
before Brown v Board of Education well
during Roe brown v board of education
bills now it continued to fall through
the 70s in the 80s but at a much slower
rate you had a much stronger black
family coming out of slavery throughout
reconstruction into Jim Crow two-parent
households were much more likely among
blacks than what you have today and in
some years according to the census
two-parent households exceeded among
blacks the rate exceeded that among the
white and and and the difference today
and I would argue largely as a result of
these efforts to help blacks you have
seen the disintegration of the black
family and until blacks repair that
damage which is in there a significant
damage
there I don't see how these other
outcomes are going to improve what can
the government do to actually if in fact
single-parent households are the problem
I will again to the title of the book
it's not about what I want the
government to do it's what I want the
governor to stop them do it stop raising
the minimum wage and pricing blacks out
of the labor force
stop mismatching kids with schools right
in the form of front of action and
setting them up to fail
stop trying to replace a father in the
home with a government check and that's
it can I ask them because you opened the
book with a discussion of the last time
that you saw your father your your
parents were divorced so you know
fathering is not I mean ideally one
assumes it's in the household with the
kids but it's not necessarily you know
you can be a parent and a father in
while not living in so the these kids
they are father's presence right in
their lives and we know all the bad
outcomes associated with not having a
father present you have people out there
calling for slavery reparations or
another huge wealth redistribution
scheme in America to help solve black
poverty here's a black poverty program
married couples in this country who are
black have a poverty rate in the single
digits and have for 20 years there's
your anti-poverty program get married
before you have kids my beef with the
black left is that they want to keep the
focus on what government or Washington
or politicians or whites in general can
do for blacks or should be doing for
blacks instead of what blacks can do for
themselves this is the polar opposite of
what you got in say Martin Luther King's
generation who made black self
development a priority right and he was
in a long line of civil rights leaders
who did that I quote from Frederick
Douglass and Booker T Washington both
men born slaves who said all we can
really ask for the government is equal
opportunity then it's up to us to take
advantage of those opportunities
now today you have civil rights leaders
saying until racism has been vanquished
from America blacks cannot be held
responsible for the criminality for the
attitudes towards education for the work
habits and so forth again the complete
opposite of what preview
and the reason behind that is because
the civil rights movement has become a
civil rights industry they have a vested
interest in keeping a certain narrative
out there to maintain their own
relevance if it really is about black
culture if it really is about a racial
conversation that black people need to
have among one another then what the
n-double-a-cp is out there trying to do
what Jesse Jackson is trying to do our
al Sharpton started is less and less
relevant so one of the reasons I wrote
the book is because I think there is an
audience for what I'm saying
a receptive audience that agrees with me
on these cultural issues even though
their supposed black leaders out there
don't want to talk about it because it's
not in their vested either who is a
younger generation of black leaders you
think that are that are sending the
right message there are people like our
tour Davis former congressman another
former congressman Harold ward jr. has
been saying these things but I don't
think it's a necessarily by the way a
Democrat from Tennessee right on the
Memphis area so I don't think it's
necessarily generational no I think you
have many ministers in the black
community many black parents who get get
what I'm saying in this book and want to
talk about these issues again they may
not self-identify as conservatives but I
think there are a lot of them out there
who share the same values so I mean your
broad thesis is that the a lot of
programs that were put in whatever their
intentions are having negative effects
because they allow the perpetuation of a
kind of dependency culture or a culture
that gives rise to a lot of social
problems
how does affirmative action fit into
well that again affirmative action
another well intentioned policy intended
to increase the ranks of the black
middle class increase the number of
black college graduates and I talked
about it in this book mostly in the
education sector and what it's done at
the higher education level in particular
and what you have is a mismatch problem
and we saw that when California ended
its ban on racial preferences back in
1996 what happened after that banned
took place is that black graduation
rates increased by more than 50%
not only overall but in some of the more
difficult disciplines
like math and science and engineering
again by more than 50% so a policy
intended to help increase the number of
black graduates was resulting in fewer
doctors fewer lawyers are gon in general
that has happened then we otherwise
would have had well what happened is
that these schools were funneling blacks
into environments where they didn't
match the educational credentials of the
average student at the school and so
they were outmatched and many of them
dropped out or switched to easier majors
after the band took place kids are being
better matched with schools where they
could do the work and therefore you had
better graduation rates but the but the
way the whole affirmative action debate
has evolved graduation rates aren't the
priority diversity was the priority the
the campus has to look like America that
the college catalog has to be properly
color-coded whether kids are actually
graduating is a secondary concern at
that's the freshman class is what
matters and a good example of this in a
nutshell is a study some years ago done
of MIT black kids at MIT black kids at
MIT the scored in the top 10% on the
math section of the SAT of all kids in
the country of any color but they were
in the bottom 10% of scores on the math
section SAT at MIT right so you have
these very smart black kids who would be
hitting it out of the park
row at a less selective school but
they're struggling at MIT and on mighty
could care less because their campus
looks like America right that leads to
one of the places where government
policy and I guess it in in the context
that we're talking about here is going
in the right direction and it's really
kind of getting out of the way of people
creating their own culture which is
school choice you write a lot about K
through 12 school choice and this is a
fascinating issue because it tends to
unite kind of libertarian or
conservatives as well as inner-city
blacks in particular right talk a little
bit about you know what what's the value
of school of school choice and why it's
a good thing that that seems to be on
the rise well it works that's the value
of it it works and the problem is that
this whole debate we have about school
it's not really about whether school
choice works it's about whether public
education should be primarily a jobs
program for adults that's the real
debate that's what do you what do you
mean by that you know worried I mean
whatever I what I mean by that is that
first of all it's hugely popular among
the very people who want it and need it
most low-income inner-city black and
Hispanic people for decades it is pulled
off the charts and I use this as another
example of the disconnect between the
black rank-and-file and the black
leadership you're Jesse Jackson's you're
all Sharpton's you're in double AC PS
tend to oppose school choice because
they are siding with the unions who do
not like it not because it doesn't work
but because many of these charter
schools and many of these schools where
the vouchers would be use aren't
organized and their primary concern are
the adults in the system not the kids
until you see them fighting for laws
that have no educational justification
lastin first-out hiring policies
there's no educational justification for
that hiring teachers after two years in
the classroom giving them a job for life
making them impossible to fire
there's no educational justification for
that those are job protections and yet
you see the unions fighting for them
even to the detriment of the children
they claim to represent and then you see
these organizations like the n-double
a-c-p who take money from the unions
siding with the unions over the kids and
the parents of the kids who they claim
to represent school choice as a movement
I mean there were no charter schools in
1996 the first one in the country opened
its doors in Minnesota in 1997 now there
are tens of thousands what has to happen
for it to become the new the new normal
one of the one of the arguments that
opponents of charter schools and
vouchers make is that they can't be
scaled up to replace our public school
system that's that's a red herring they
don't need to be scaled up we don't need
a Kipp in every neighborhood in America
I live in suburban New York City we
don't need a camp up there the public
schools are just fine
right so this we know where we need
these schools we need them in our inner
cities you know in our most difficult
neighborhoods with the kids facing the
most challenges and that's where these
schools one
to be located and that's what we need we
don't need them everywhere so this
argument that oh we can't voucherize the
whole system or create charter eyes the
whole system so we can't do anything is
it is a Dodge and it should be dismissed
out of hand but where these schools are
locating they are getting results but
you do have a leadership out there from
the President on down who talks one game
but his actions do something different
so he talks a lot about school choice
but his administration is trying to shut
down a voucher program in Louisiana room
he talks a lot about school choice but
he's been trying to shut down a voucher
program in DC since the day he entered
the Oval Office the President of the
United States has never found a public
school good enough for his own children
either before he was president or since
he tells us be patient I'll fix those
public schools while his kids attend
private schools so and again he has an
old other agenda which is to continue
his support from labor from the teachers
unions from others who have a vested
interest in the status quo no matter
what no matter that that status quo is
harming harming our most vulnerable kids
I think it's appalling speaking of Obama
when he was you know when he was elected
many people both on the right and left
you start your book with a kind of
discussion of you know this really this
is like a pretty great moment where you
know finally America has like moved past
a certain stage in race relations do you
think kind of discussions of race have
gotten better or worse or are they or at
least we having more now since Obama has
become president and we should we look
forward to a period and how would we get
there where race is no longer the kind
of open wound and that it seems to be an
American political and cultural
discourse
we're not post-racial but I'd argue that
the left has no interest in being
post-racial they claim they want to be
post-racial but they really don't they
want to keep race front and center in
our national conversations because it
serves their agenda that racism is the
all-purpose explanation for what ails
black America there are a lot of people
making a lot of money on that there
and they want to keep it out there there
are political parties who who gain and
keep political power with that narrative
out there and they want to keep talking
about it by the same token I mean you
know I I mean I'm not a partisan one way
or the other I don't know that you are
but you know what is the Republican
Party doing to send a message to you
know both to black America I mean what
what they've been Romney get now what
should what should they be doing and how
responsible are they for the fact that
they're lucky if they get 5% of the the
black vote and it was you know there was
a time when the Republican Party
actually was the black part oh yeah
these things these things change over
time
loyalty to parties change over time
that's certainly true there is some
black outreach among the GOP today you
have people like Paul Ryan making an
effort Chris Christie and his reelection
bid in New Jersey when in the Camden
introduced himself did pretty well among
blacks in the past you've had people
like Jack Kemp known for his work in the
inner cities you had Richard Riordan out
in LA at Steven Goldsmith and
Indianapolis but those still tend to be
exceptions by and large serious black
outreach does not occur among Republican
candidates and I don't ascribe that to
racial animus Nick I think they're being
very pragmatic they feel they don't need
this vote to win and they feels time
spent courting a constituency they're
not likely to get a big return on its
time not spent courting someone else and
I don't think that's really going to
change until the Republican Party feels
they need the black vote to win you were
speaking about immigration earlier right
now there's a huge debate in the GOP
about the Latino vote and whether they
can continue to win elections going
forward without more of this voting room
there is no such discussion about blacks
right among the GOP right now and I
don't think you're going to get one
until they feel they need this group to
to to win elections I wish they would do
more black outreach and the black
outreach that they do is pretty much
laughable going to the n-double-a-cp
every four years to give a speech is not
black outreach those folks were probably
lost to the GOP I like what Rand Paul is
doing and going into black colleges
to get that younger generation but
that's what you need to do you need to
go into the barber shops you need to go
into the community centers the churches
introduce yourself the the habit among
Republican candidates these days is
really to just concede that vote make
symbolic thing statement so I support
school choice and maybe that will win me
a few votes you've got to do more than
that thanks we'll leave it there we've
been talking with Jason Riley he is the
author most recently of please stop
helping us how liberals make it harder
for blacks to succeed for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie
[Music]
you